the sixth day in january in 2021
will never be forgotten on this day in
washington
d.c a mob descended upon the united
states capital
rioting both outside and inside
in response to how it came to pass and
how it was handled was responded to by
the players in this arena tonight
as we have seen in this return to arenas
around the nba
most teams most players stood for the
anthem on this night
celtics and heat in response to the
world's greatest symbol of
self-government
being ransacked today all took a knee
myers leonard very similar to what
occurred
in the bowl standing in his connection
and fully understanding that with his
family connection to the military a
statement delivered by the celtics and
the heat
jointly 2021 is a new year
but some things have not changed we
played tonight's game with
heavy hearts after gear stays decision
in kenosha and knowing that protests in
our
nation's capital are treated differently
by political leaders depending on what
side
of the certain issues they are on the
stress
difference between the way protesters
this past spring and summer were treated
and the engagement given to today's
protesters
who acted legally just shows how much
more work we have to do
you might hear some responses a little
bit later from coaches
on both sides right now it is time to
ball y'all with the call here is
eric and john gentlemen well thank you
very much jack
sports in the nba sometimes serves as a
great distraction to the
events swirling around our world we hope
this heat celtics game will do that
for all of you out there in heat nation
take your minds off
the very sad and near tragic events of
the day
now let's focus in and enjoy some nba
hoops he